hey guys real quick we want to give you
a heads up this video has some imagery
as well as some sounds of violence from
the recent protests so just be warned
you also want to let you know there is a
podcast out now that you can listen to
about the protests and tomorrow we will
be releasing a follow-up episode July
4th exploring the idea of whiteness and
I will be talking to my family about how
they are perceiving this moment so give
it a listen thank you for watching and
stay safe I'm afraid I'm afraid when I
see the police every single time because
I don't know what that interaction is
gonna lead to
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Brian I'm 28 years old
I'm a police officer in Michigan I've
been doing this for four years my name
is Gloria I'm with the Youth Justice
Coalition based in LA and I'm 24 years
old
my name is Dorian 30 years old from
Compton California I'm a peace officer
my name is will I'm 42 years old I'm a
former police officer I did that for
about 18 years my name is Ethan I'm 19
years old I'm from Indianapolis Indiana
I'm a junior supply chain management
major from dehy University so my name is
Tennessee I am 22 years old I'm from New
York City and I'm just a simple
protester
turn your camera off if this is not true
for you
I've witnessed police brutality I mean
it's it's happened more than one time
and the two times that it's happened
it's been because I've been pulled over
because I've been with my friends that
have like tattoos and just like being
told to get on the ground like just
listening to the officers um
demands and still being pushed to the
ground but also seeing officers get
really upset if you begin to like ask
for an attorney or a lawyer I mean when
I was attended to Indianapolis protests
for J sorry when um after the protest
when I was going to my car I was seen by
four officers but I seen my cars in my
car over here across the street so I'm
just like excuse me officers like this
buy four of them I was like I'm trying
to get to my car and they were like now
go home and one of them push me which I
seen that's unnecessary
so I did put some back which is
something I said us in the door and I
look at it but like me getting pushed
back and then give pepper spray I seen
that is you know kind of overuse of
force growing up my best friend was
Hispanic and had cousins that were
troublemakers and gangs so on a few
occasions the gang squad in the city I
grew up and would pull us over pull
everybody out kind of manhandle us there
was another time where it's not
excessive force but I was a victim of a
robbery and I knew the suspect and I was
you know juvenile and made a police
report and nothing ever came of it so
just remembering that when I got older
and became a police officer that you
want to be treated fairly and you also
have to treat people fairly
so I've never witnessed it but I've been
in plenty of situations where there's a
dog pile on the ground you have to
apprehend somebody it's a lawful arrest
and they want to put up a flight but if
I ever see anything where someone's
continuing to apply pressure or you know
give it a knee or something push them
away say hey we're good we got him in
custody that's the end of it and the
George Floyd cases is huge you see those
officers just standing around I don't
understand why none of them rip that guy
off his back this is more a question for
the officers do you approve of some of
the crowd control tactics that you've
seen in the videos of these protests we
are okay with your person when the right
to protest that's what this country is
built on but you do have provocateurs
you do have agitators in the crowd it to
me
it just doesn't seem like everything is
always peaceful no matter what and then
it just goes to show I I don't know I'm
okay with something I'm not okay with
others I just I don't know as a
protester I'm just not sure it's for any
protest even if it gets a little more
like loud not a problem
okay chaos is the problem I just don't
know if it's like appropriate to use
tear gas or rubber bullets tear gas can
actually kill someone it agitates asthma
and rubber bullets can cause serious
damage depending on where you hay made
one you know what I mean I just don't
know if that's like appropriate and
perfectly okay with that my only problem
is give me a solution what other things
do you think that we should do as
opposed to that - de-escalating because
de-escalation requires cooperation if
I'm telling you hey let's bring it down
you're not listening to me then it's not
effective right because we have to
maintain order that is kind of my my my
desk my profession that's my job looting
and destruction of property are
acceptable parts of protesting
[Music]
I think it is acceptable and I know I'll
be challenged for this at every single
stage but I think that one we need to
recognize that were on stolen land two
we need to recognize that folks that
have been completely robbed and stolen
from their land their people their roots
and I think that more people need to
really instead of focusing and putting
all that hate on people that are looting
think about what caused all that anger
so when I went to my protest it was
really peaceful it's still like about
like non-attendance you see people like
starting to throw stuff at buildings and
it really is people are just mad people
are frustrated and trying to get their
anger out and you will see the structure
you will see violence because people are
tired of being hurt and it's not
something I can don't but it's something
that will happen because it is people
that do it also a lot of the times
looters just be trying to hit links I
gotta be honest I see people that just
like you know take advantage of the
situation that people are like breaking
inside block all about to go hit that
Bank real quick I'm about to hit that
store real quick so for black people out
there please do not look because they're
gonna push you as it does and they're
gonna make it seem like you're the bad
guy at the end of the day when white
people lose their gonna call them
employees and it's ypres what black
people oooh or black people rap they're
gonna call us first and excuse it to the
racist narrative that in turn is just
gonna come and just make Lakers look
worse there's a lot of people who don't
understand the struggle of black
community they don't understand how life
is living in an inner city I didn't I
grew up in a suburb and it was like 98%
white I was very sheltered but I'll say
for all the people who are sheltered out
there and it's probably the vast
majority of America it's gonna be really
hard for them to sympathize and
empathize with the black lives matter
movement when they start seeing looters
when they start seeing buildings burning
they're just gonna think oh wow like you
guys are acting ridiculous but your
voice is very powerful it's important
for folks to remember that this is not a
moment this is a movement
folks are uprising because they're tired
and sick and tired of the same things
happening over and over and over
right looting might not be right right
but like I said if it's not right what
about when folks were enslaved what
about all the gold I was thinking what
about all these things what about the
the land right so no III do stand in
solidarity with folks that are doing the
looting that are doing the uprisings
that are in the protests because there's
there's layers to this the recent
protests are risking lives and likely
spreading Koba 19
[Music]
the other day you guys see it for what
it is and it is a whole lot of people
standing together even though I do see
it's just causing I which approaches
myself I think it's just cause they're
not doing right for my people by the end
they just guys see it for what it is and
it could potentially spread covert
justice Trump roschin spread Kobe just
as people opening their businesses can
spread covert just as people open their
restaurants to spread Kobe I get it I
understand the protest I understand what
people are tired I understand that
people who are tired of being tired so I
mean if it's a risk they're willing to
take by all means
and you at the end of the day will reap
the consequences or the benefits of your
decision of course most you know you can
probably likely to get sick from Kobe 19
but they're also people giving out PPE
and you know they're encouraging
everyone wear masks and a lot of
protests even though it doesn't tend to
happen they do advertise hey can you say
six feet apart that'd be great I would
rather fight for something I believe in
and die for what I believe in people
want to always shut down people power
and they always want to make sure that
we're Slyke oh now now it's like it's
your fault you're you are making sure
that the pandemic is thriving no let's
look at it as a whole let's look at how
law enforcement officers are not wearing
any masks right and and I saw it first
time because when I was arrested again
the officers doing intake the officers
doing process processing the officers on
the bus we're not wearing any masks and
when we asked them why are you not
wearing masks wearing masks and they
were like oh we're six feet apart from
you on why you're not you're asking me
where my arm where my number is to book
me so let's look at that and let's also
bring that out to the media - one thing
I don't wear a mask when I'm going on
duty I don't wear a mats and that's my
personal choice I am also not gonna look
at you and say hey hey hey you over
there why are you not wearing a mask why
are you I'm not gonna do that that is
your personal choice that is you I do
know that I've seen people try to switch
the narrative but that's from the media
that's not normal people medias nothing
not normal people most normal people are
not going to be complaining that you
don't have a mask no island I perfectly
understand that I'm just saying that a
lot of people watch the media and so
then they'll put tray these protests
right very different and so just like
you said right you don't wear a mask
right that's fine
I do think you should wear a mask for
your safety because it is a pandemic and
to me it is real and I want to respect
other people's face and other people's
opinions I do want to make sure that I
had a mask just keep just to keep people
safe
law enforcement in the US has become too
militarized
one or two things in the car that needs
to be reformed or there needs to be a
demilitarized edition a lot of these
instances occur because police have
using that are far wrong unjustly so
let's take the case of Rashard Brooks
for example it all started because he
was asleep at a McDonald's it was
something so light they ended with him
getting shot in the back
you said I'm saying so at the end of the
day it's like why do these things get
escalated so much where these things
have to occur where lethal force has to
occur you could have chased them you
could have found him later like at the
end the day there's other ways around
the other than lethal force I wanted to
go back to what Dorian was bringing up
around like what do we do maybe if
officers weren't killing people maybe
that would be a solution
maybe if an LA County LAPD wouldn't have
killed around 900 people right 900
individuals and we're talking about over
militarization of law enforcement why is
it that there's a helicopter that you'll
have SWAT what type of guns do you all
have all the weapons that you all carry
what's really necessary because tax
dollars are paying for that maybe we
need to clarify what militarization
means right because you say that what
weapons are you guys using alright there
are three deadly weapons in my vehicle
at one time my service pistol my shotgun
and my rifle the other tools that I have
are tools to use tools that I'm gonna
use so somebody doesn't end up dying
so my taser pepper spray my baton grant
it can we be trained better absolutely I
don't train that often I should but when
you say that's over militarize I'm not
understanding what that means I don't
use military weapons so I just want to
point out that we as police officers we
don't want to kill people
that's not our objective we want
everyone to go home safely
I've been in multiple situations where I
have had my gun on plane that's somebody
and I'll point out one example there's a
drunk guy behind the wheel stop that at
a green light he has a gun right there
in the passenger seat he keeps reaching
for his gun keeps reaching for it and
thank God that I didn't shoot him I
could have legally shot him
was so close to picking off that gun and
pointing to that we carry a shotgun a
rifle and a pistol these are all weapons
that the general public has access to as
well if they have access to it we have
to have access to it I can remember a
couple of the incidents that caused the
police departments it started with the
FBI in Miami were there they were
outgunned back in the 80s and that's
what caused I believe to go to automatic
handguns as opposed to revolvers and
then it was the LA bank robberies where
those officers are outgunned and with
all the school shootings and at the same
time 911 hit and a lot of the local
jurisdictions wanted to be able to
maintain law and order in case of a
terrorist attacked and not be outgunned
in that circumstance so I agree with you
- a regard that we had become I wouldn't
call a militarized but we have become
more prepared in law enforcement to
handle any situation
there are times and we can throw out
numerous including George Floyd that
that meant to do with militarization
that was a bad cop
I wanted to go back to some something
that was pointed out earlier about SWAT
80% of SWAT raids according to the ACLU
are by drug offences and I do agree with
Ethan that it's not needed the SWAT team
is not needed for a drug case you don't
need to shoot someone for dealing drugs
for selling drugs or for using drugs I
don't think that's really appropriate I
definitely do think race is an issue
when it comes to these raids
statistics have shown that black and
span people are likely to be
incarcerated for these things and what
black people make up only 13% of the
population and Hispanics make up about
like what I think 18% I support
defunding the police
[Music]
and just to make sure everybody who's
cameras on you are in support of
defunding the police I don't know enough
about it and we did not know what that
would look like to defund the police I'm
alerting you guys with you Europeans are
on there how you see defunded the police
happening at the yjc were no cops on so
we don't work with police we don't allow
police in our space and we've been
calling for five percent of law
enforcement's budget which is a campaign
that we have that's about defunding the
police and we do practice transformative
justice we are creating this thing
called community alternatives to 9-1-1
where different folks um that have
different like backgrounds as they're
like medical backgrounds are able to
support with like trauma and sexual
assault mental health when we think
about crime I think that the worst thing
that that this brings up sometimes is
that what about the murderers what about
the rapist what about school shootouts
right if you're getting to the root
causes of things like those surface
things might or might not expand and I
think using that taking the money from
law enforcement and again like putting
that into schools putting that into
parks putting that into youth
development youth jobs I've heard these
plans where people I would say minor
mental health crises neighbor disputes
civil I'm okay if you do fund the police
if that means you're taking resources
from policing shifting it to those other
departments or whatnot and having them
handle it so I can go out and get the
murderers or the rapists and this and
that they're the robbers and all that
stuff it's just rhetoric to me is
important when you say be fun the police
okay I'm gonna take that as literal and
then what the hell does that mean other
than taking away our budget having less
cops but we're still done with the same
amount of workload that we were doing
before you gonna burn me out
so I disagreed with defunding the police
I do completely agree you need more
money being pumped into these resources
especially in these inner cities the
school systems a joke and that's all
over the nation you know why is it that
I got to go to a school where I had all
these sports programs that were
completely paid for and I had all these
at a business club I got to be a part of
these other communities don't have that
and it's not fair but defunding the
police I also think it's a bad idea
because if you just take money away the
problems aren't going to solve
themselves immediately so I think
money's gonna have to come from
elsewhere I mean you look at all these
monopolies getting away with tax evasion
and in our country that's disgusting in
itself why are these huge corporations
getting away with so much they're
getting richer and richer and richer
meanwhile people at the very bottom the
low-income are just gonna keep getting
stepped on unless things change from the
top you got to remember that if you want
the best and the brightest police
officers you got to pay for it and also
you start taking away funding from
police departments and cities the those
extras that really help like the
advocates in the assistance and those
social workers they're gonna be the
first to go and it's going to be the
patrol officers that stay 2011-2012
Governor Christie took away money from
New Jersey
Camden was forced to cut twenty percent
of its budget the Washington posted
great article on this and what happened
is they had a strong police union so
they went in and got rid of the police
by taking away the whole department
brought in a county sheriff's department
to cover it crime went down because they
did the whole broken window theory but
what did go up was excessive force
complaints so the numbers are always
skewed but at the end of the day it took
the activists and it took this the
citizens working with the police to get
both the crime down and to get the use
of force in the police officer
complaints down now I think during a hit
is spot-on because if they if this was
to occur maybe relocating these
resources elsewhere where people won't
always have to feel like oh I'm gonna
call the police you know what every
situation
we got people who you got carriers up in
Manhattan can't call the police on black
man for bird watching and doing
things like police did not be the first
ones to call for every little situation
there are more good cops than bad
you
[Music]
there's about 800 thousand cops in
America right take me for example I
usually do about at about 10 to 20 calls
so on average there's about eight
million police-citizen encounters on the
day to day basis I don't think that a
majority of us or even half of us are
going around just messing people love
kicking people's ass all that stuff
we're just trying to do the best that we
can
yes there are some people out here who
have nefarious reasons to becoming a cop
I don't think that's the majority of us
I see my partners on a day-to-day basis
I know my partners I see how other
people interact I see other from other
states I just have to say that most cops
are good cops most cops are good people
that's just my experience I can't speak
for everybody else but that's my
experience yeah I agree and I think it's
just like in the light we are right now
so many bad cops are being portrayed on
this and it's just like people are just
seeing them all the bad cop so myself
I've had more good experiences with cops
they're bad experiences I can't say for
everybody but you know that's just been
my experience a I'd really do not think
all cops a bit or most types of bet
effect I think it's important to point
out too that law enforcement it's one of
the only professions where one incident
we all get lumped into it you know a
teacher sleeps with an underage student
we don't go around saying all teachers
are bad and I think a lot of it has to
do with the fact that law enforcement is
one of the only professions that can
restrict people's rights if you look at
the numbers alone majority police are
having great if not positive encounters
with citizens um I think I'm a family
member who is a cop and of course I
think she's a good person but I think
the whole well not all cops are bad
again it takes away from the
conversation we all know that not all
cops are bad but the conversation we're
trying to have it's not all cops are
good either I had a friend who was raped
by the cop I mean a cop is not in jail
no he's still working
she tried reporting it nothing happened
I just think again it's like a
deflection strategy
the reason why we did like what the [ __ ]
all right what did I do is because
rhetoric I'm not gonna tell anybody has
but rhetoric is very important right so
we say cops kill people I've never
killed anybody in my life
right so you automatically have brought
me into that conversation so work I'm
like no not all cops bring people I'm
not trying to go away from the from the
subject matter when you do a broad thing
like that because like I said me I'm
like what this is not about good cop bad
cop
it's about that the system needs to be
dismantled as a whole it's about
remembering how the system was built the
system of policing right and it was
built to catch thieves it's about the
fact that you all work for institutions
that continuously show up to hurt harm
I was arrested at the age of eleven and
even just thinking about that right
policing and young people being um being
arrested and in juvenile halls and
almost things right all these systems
that that's what policing is like you're
on the wrong side you know and I'm also
thinking about I have a daughter too and
her father was severely beat by the
police by LAPD once at court the cop was
not convicted of anything but it was
brought up that he this specific officer
had been also beating different people
yeah he was still he was still in the
field he was still working he was still
getting paid policing as a whole and the
system that is up like is Thai is like
grabbing on to systemic racism right
because when you think about who are in
these prisons who are in these jails who
is in custody you're talking you're
talking about black and brown people so
it doesn't matter if there's the black
cop is the Latino cup is the white cup
like if you're seeing their injustice
going on in the departments because I
know you all see it in different levels
um and and you're not saying anything
and what can you really say right and
that's I'm not done talking to him I
know no I'm not gonna start talking for
you I'm not
um because like you all want to cover
each other's asses or whatever and
that's okay but at the end of the day it
wasn't one cop it wasn't three cops that
killed 948 people it was several cups
that have not been incited by the
district attorney or by anyone else so
why are we gonna keep the the little
narrative around good call backup no the
whole system needs to go and see this is
the exact thing that I was talking about
which I'm not what I want to go back and
forth and I didn't mean to cut you out
that that was that was I apologize for
that
but the problem is you keep speaking for
me right so now you said you know that
that's exactly what you said you guys
know this you do like you don't know
nothing about me you don't know anything
about me I don't know anything about you
so I would never serve what I've gone
through in my life on you that's what
you just I'm not talking about Dorian
because the question question was around
good cop bad cop is important because
that's what you said you said you are
three you guys know all three you guys
know what I'm talking about
law enforcement because that's what the
question is centered around you can't
that's why I said rhetoric to me is most
important because we're having a
conversation you and I glory you you
everybody is here is having a
conversation so we say you I have never
seen this before personally I've never
seen something like that right if I did
you damn right I would say something I
don't give a [ __ ] if I lose my job okay
because I got in this to do the right
thing I'm afraid I'm afraid when I see
the police every single time because I
don't know what that interaction is
gonna meet to I don't know if you are
having a good day because you'll have
more power in terms of power dynamics
whether you can escalate and whether you
know because now I'm a threat for
whatever maybe I might have said
something maybe I have something maybe I
made the wrong move you may be afraid
because your experiences that's fine I'm
not taking away from anything but
there's also other viewpoints right not
just yours
I respect your viewpoint right I would
actually recommend because you're afraid
to go on a ride-along to see what we do
you may not want to I got you I got you
I'm just saying just to see because
people think I'm 30 years old right I've
only been a cop for seven years that
doesn't take my sense of humanity out of
me just because I became a law
enforcement officer alright I'm not
taking anything
from anyone I think our country will
make it through these divisive times
I mean I think we would I know we will
because this is a stepping point for our
country and you know people are waking
up and wanted a better nation for
everybody for all of us at the end of
the day there might be bloodshed there
might be large loss there might be you
know tears crying whatever African
American people in this country been
through for Jesus like we've been
through Jim Crow we've been through the
60s you've been to every day so we
definitely gonna make it though I think
it starts with what we're doing here it
starts with communication I think it
turn off TV a little when it comes to
being manipulated by the news and you
know things kind of die down but what it
really takes is not forcing somebody to
see your view but to actually
communicate and come up with a solution
working with both sides and I think if
we do that there will definitely be
stronger for from it it's what we don't
know that scares us but when we open up
and see the other people's points of
view and you see how other people live
and their expectations I think we can
get a lot farther I was a part of a
protest with there called the New York
City students for justice and we're
talking high schoolers who are 17 and 18
year old year olds they're organizing
their own protests that thousands of
people attended I just it gave me a lot
of hope because I'm like these kids are
gonna get far I definitely think they're
the future for our country you guys
saying that just gives me hope because I
guess I'm cynical I think that people I
think we're going to destroy each other
before that happens you're right the
younger people younger people the
younger generation are the future and
like we'll say it all starts with
conversation so I'm gonna change my
answer now so I'm sorry to be so
negative but I think all of us law
enforcement and the communities we serve
I think we want to work together we need
your guys support to do our jobs but the
fact of the matter is there's so much
corruption out there at the higher
levels and I don't think it's gonna
change I think the more that we
communicate on our levels is really
important and it can somewhat keep the
peace but as a whole things are not
going to change until the higher ups
start doing something
what's happening in America yeah I'm
just I'm just really at night I want to
acknowledge the fact that if these
systems don't change we will continue to
be uprising we will continue to have
protests have demands have solutions and
I was really just remembering all the
moms that I've heard had their they
loved ones or their sons killed by law
enforcement and what would they want to
see what justice do they deserve right
what what justice does George Floyd
deserve does what Keisha Wilson does
Breanna right like all the N is so many
what what what justice do they deserve
this is not gonna stop until again until
we have changed you guys are all great I
appreciate you I'm gonna ask that you
all log out and just kind of say goodbye
to each other
close it ask Laurie or something though
damn everyone